in 2005 what alain from good afternoon
tour to the love you the designers week
are the origin the year of grace to the water
elsewhere am very happy to meet you in
europe
house in london indian which he
trades a large she would like  all 5
2 you delegation of ambassadors
joao vale de almeida common form at 5
euros
should your work you to represent the
young uk together we of colors is even
y plays ambassador's ounaïes but you have
express negotiations of middle of
various health economic and  social a
double 6 3 6 10 as duty to act
responsible i in turkish fornas grint
meetings negative consequence to loans
site this is why citrus fruits for this
week
the idiot think they are important
and where the two including president
ursula von der  leyen charles michel
hot responsibility unity dina grings
the badge is strong next seven years
and very abichou recovery
yuping plan speaking debating say all
from 19 20 the ethnic group begin with a few
words  of context out of israel around
12:08 p.m. presidency
ursula try and david it's solid
charles michel in june of tram minister
boris johnson todateen title which
apolitics the mantis crane quickly the
first strauss at the stadium free ride and
now one new role to of  open khordad
justice in the uk and able to dry of 2
ends future uequeloz without against
years a citrus fisheries tape thing to
brax it makes real difference that we
lose everything existing if you fail is
directly from the finger
johnson wright 16 matters everything said two
times
following the arrival meetings or hagrid
twenty five disc thing we have tried
in dust and stripes randstad a at 10 rue
redline what a disc world our
commitment than comprehensive new
partnership to this high political idea
she decoration signed by by minsk
johnson 1 221  av october last year
mykonos and ni international to green it
right constrained to the parties all
youyous of morobe 10 aces of jack and we
have continued d'une guédj  sincerely and
constructive lies in line with the band
aid given to at spy 2 had me states with
the support of the year a palme a
river of the past few weeks the hot uk arnott
sows the thieves
engagment endredi snow everything done
solution respecting dinghies
fundamental main stakeholders
say yes that there are constructive
discussions at the top under a good and
services
vadis negotiations a complex and we cry
is unique is progressing a cross all you
all and style far away district
discussion nearby it is a positive
atmosphere it happens in everything  5 david
frost india esteem in douala you you
team ford and professionals approach
very professional brings the state
of aude as to make some progress
youssoufou discussion turned raw power
diversity coordination 1 union program
yes but you are progressing towers
comprehensive objective in single institutional
famous rock witchu cloud drive is a
force same mechanism
and we had kourt discussions in police
j  judiciary cooperation ivan lively
differences
rim is in all the importance goal
transports energy we are in time is
useful hard luck
however from uk continued to request
single market like profits more
sad they seem to us
not progressing in all essentials topix
power like economic partnership first
air must be robust guarantees strong
level penalty field including anstett
and an open day antoine stand to
compete in my case or business is all
role savior talent
if the body interest for all
winter peak states and my view
also for uk second jamming  from the
grid in balance system of
long term leases solutions for fish harris
tweed interest of burma bastide
concerned in mind to our list of
manila men and women you are
used to
the eee pad on it and boys the design of the
group in china  note comme à soup rase
we have been seen the same thing since
the beginning of the negotiations
our lisieux constanty plis over de l  a
silky dispose to mansion explicitly in
the political declaration razer resize
text women of framework of basics of
fundamental framework of 10 negotiations
drilling terror skates not alone to have
politics in guinea
the spirit minister boris johnson is
months ago we at saint-prix asking simply
as que tout france the 10 politics a
fortnight into league text nothing more
once again the prime minister rights and
size matters sweet of all the same
mansion do not want a line of a
fisheries said this weekend and uk
of inapt shoah willingness to break  of
deadlock by developing a field of uk
east and refuses in any case me to maintain
in eyes stand up in meaningful way and
state aid who spy of customers wording of
policy young people want to clear
arm you to take us wrongly from
6 or death  warning because we have no
visibility in mourning or what is
international future domestic
it was 10 control system a regime
respects and uk politics ribes is of
fransen size of french time
since weekly running out important and
laughing the climate and found the good ones
only one batch of uk refused effective means
the void hunter cutting ballerinas
stangl uk once again it really autonomy
ok + respect at your camp of uk use in
your eyes  inside nominal rates
say all competitions luiz as we
have to answer discretion
ah yes comic you new economic
partnership
we want to tribe d uk free fanta is free
form quotas this boat offered itself form
in competing with duke and business one
that to  the uk spaces and need
some tea for its 1010
canadian hockey from price to the long term
uncertain tools saying advantageous
for our business and day where you
respect and uk government's political
chase and ready to have a solution of
you cannot accept and will  not accept
football bill ford and uk is political and
joris albi very clear that may be very
clear less ambitious agreements goods
and serious an app do  you to drop in
the demon's forge list the
windsurfers in fischer and the duke is
effective and what to remember
total excludes young girls or phishing
vasseur family uk porthos athos an
acceptable price from uk wilburn independent
coastal state to diouf or respect them
organizers of future agreements term
ebit changes all of benefit of uk
fichman comstock this need to be manage
john kerry accordingly international
aux 1/2 main manager insists
annie ball management offers on sun amy
agreements channels triple a day
destruction of yiwu phishing industry
repeat we have  to grid in balanced
buy long-term leases
solve false fisheries protecting from
mad men and women use livelihood from ipad
to notes
ladies and gentlemen from you always in
cistude from an economic partnership from uk
must include robust le ring rouge  to
danic witbooi agreements and fisheries
10 mins simply died of use to commit de
conditioneurs competition and balanced
citrus darling maiden of uk makes
the trade agreement said this bears a
notice
until the very offshore
negotiations clues heart straw
troubled of you will remain in games
constructive a spectra he indicated of uk
single market book hot  n'est
parti union rend frost january next
year in little more in five of fame
ans this will bring inevitable tianzhu
in advance hyde we are getting ready
fabris communication a few days ago
and to the citizens business in public
administration ripert needs
period transition indies  in the face of threats
and leaders with grid 10 week five
billion us special
brick instruments site adjustment reaser of canter
in force india wants to consequences
hinman states and sectors data worst
affected in their excites a parallel
then to this famous bridge over seventy
seven of the sector  specific our
former president testers said what
action economic merit sector to be
ready photo12 of tra  nsition period 19.6
hammam of atari reading force sets 2d
fed up with nawa uk task force group
fishing at bruce lee
ladies and gentlemen we do not great
shenae grimes and speed earth wind and
women and our future partnership of erbil
by  far more friction fine stance trading
good in addition to newcastle this strong
marri tease of will be dried up a quota of
6 of all orders etc if you decide everything
is going site under will continue to
tell of all
if we want to avoid the additional
friction predicted  that it prohibits any
force in de frost january next sure that
they means that we only a few weeks
left and that which would not west it
is ripe sorry my view that we only have
little time a popoli sentheim college
implements of withdraw  to green it
together with vice president of
commission maros sefcovic but continue
to follow closely implementation lease
of uk its ungrateful commitment of protocol
in thailand adt north said nothing this
context of the leader before  the gray care
in the world of canvases with
android quests 1.6 million euros of peace
place program in support of peace that
you go thing one to continue his
work we rehash cross border coprin
chauny the round ruining special
committee of doors colonna and our news
flocked young people from texting cac progresses to
nailloux like to 5 michael gove indices
team for the young and that women
concern the deal and his sisters and my
players will not been pressure from frost
january reduce we made you there is no
grace period needs own
implementation  ordis protocol and filed
under qui topic of the wild hunt women
vigilante together with pointis value
governments and the european parliament
all guaranteed rights of british
nationals cover by the wild one women
living in one hour
when israel and the state of
sentheim knows - quick  specter rights of you
need is us and uk to be c'est le garde
all ladies and men in london eye
surrounded in furnes by yooz willingne  ss to
reach ambitious partnership agreement
in all and play at inc loading even
layton external security and defense
meanwhile of 10 pieces of wish of de
presents ursula von der leyen charles
michel de yop speaking 12.6 seven
and governance
he continues to believe that  ramiste
bruce johnson one of the uk government's
want to find agreements with you because
it is simple in our comme interest to
operate and to address
mais ni un very serious challenger of
today climate change and biodiversity
and security research and innovation
ring-shaped democracy tiles  from
fight against poverty and financial
stability in fine a beautiful finish line
from saint-exupéry negotiations 19 to
look
in all this pic to you our houses said
look to gather in from sem direction to
will be back in london with my team next
week to this  plan d'une force in mid
auguste work
continued originally remains in germany
these regimes when we talk
about state aid
we are at the heart of a very  s serious and
very serious for us I believe also
for the British which is that of the
conditions to ensure what we
call open to a sphere competition
fair trade and
is open which is I believe useful and
necessary for everyone not
only for companies but
also for consumers and
we need at the heart of this issue to
make an open competition we
need a robust system of control
of state aids on both
sides and a form of
consistency or equivalence between our
systems provided that it exists and
that is the problem we have
today we had to side with the
european union state aid regime which
is well known that the united kingdom
knows  well and that he will leave on
December 31 and we
Europeans need to know the future
British system of what is called in the
regime of being teta so this is the
request that we are making to see it
clearly and p  To be able to work on one
of the key points of this level playing
field in terms of state aid,
I understand that's what Vacuums told me
that the United Kingdom is in the midst of a
debate on this issue at government level.
at the level of the parliament
we understand the time necessary for
this debate but we must strive to get this
debate done quickly enough so that
we can see it clearly when
concluding this negotiation
first of all we are in a negotiation
which is very serious and very complex
much more complex than
some think
with a lot of consequences me
I don't have this word of bring back
chip
I don't believe in this method in such a
complex negotiation moreover
I observe that in all
trade negotiations and the
european union have conducted many of them and
even recently with japan
south korea canada the united kingdom have
conducted at this very moment with the
united states new
zealand austral  ie or japan
we do not proceed with this method
there of mist and cheap it is
too serious a matter if I may say so
we have to build a
lasting partnership between the British economy and
the European economy which are among the
most active and most dynamic economies in
the world with
innumerable consequences for improving
if we succeed the life the work
of companies and consumers
all of this cannot be improvised and all of this
is not done under threat or
ultimatums so  II have never seen a
negotiation conducted in this way
and I think that we don't have
time for this kind of game here we are
talking about luck abdou dieye from
chernozem after taking new
risks
there are risks in our deals
objectively as long as the
British positions on two important weights that
they are at the heart of the
interests of the demands of the
European Union in this negotiation
the level playing field q  which concerns the
whole economy of the european union
and 27 countries
and obviously the question of fishing
as long as the
British mergers are blocked that
we will not have a reciprocal opening
compared to the openings that I have made that
our  European places on subjects which
are subjects of British interest
so there is an objective risk of our 10
here I must recall that on the two
subjects which I have just mentioned as
on others global governance respect
for certain fundamental principles  in
terms of police and
judicial cooperation for the protection of
citizens
the european positions are not
tactile pollution economic blows
these are serious fundamental positions
and we must find
dynamic compromises on this subject
as our president ursula von der
leyen said  a few weeks ago we
are ready to negotiate until the last
day where from can i tell
chris morris thanks  to this camera that what
he has as a feeling about me
is exactly the opposite of the
truth
as far as I'm concerned one thing that's
true is that never had enthusiasm
for the break site
it's not  a surprise I've always
said no one has been able to
show me the slightest added value of the
break site but it's a reality
the
institutional and political break site is
now realized I point out to
chris morris that it was realized from
in an orderly manner thanks to a clever one that
we signed with the first bowl
johnson and that was ratified by the
house of commons by the
british parliament and by the european parliament
me it's been four years since i
have had the honor of driving  this
negotiation on behalf of the european union
with all the teams of the
european commission and i am working for an
agreement i am working for an orderly break site
we have come a long
way a big part of the way when
it comes to  u institutional
and political divorce that we now have
to organize to succeed that is my objective
an agreement has said a lot on the
economic and commercial sites break and for
the moment we are not there equivalent
match it is not quite  that's
how complex negotiations are adorned
I actually did a few
weeks ago in the context of respecting my
opening mandate on what I
recalled earlier in my opening
remarks the three red lines indicated
personally  by boris johnson on the
justice coast british sovereignty with
regard to these laws on fishing
before going further we expect
reciprocal openness on the subjects which
are those where the european union has marked
since the beginning priorities which still
once are not
tactical or short-term priorities, so the
moment when two Britons
will come to us with a real
desire to compromise on these
important issues for the u  European nion as
we are ready has confirmed that we are
going to 20
the on subjects of importance for the
united kingdom so very frankly I
say it to the book has it will not take
much time to consolidate these
dynamic compromises by texts besides I
reminds you that the month of March
we put on the table text follows i
almost complete on the other side the
British have also done a very big
job to present legal texts
so for the drafting of the texts from
the moment we are  agreement we
do not need a lot of
time provided we have the sincere
and unambiguous basis for a compromise and an
agreement between us on
multiple and different issues
frankly I first I read
the press articles  British with a
lot of attention it is always very
stimulating to read the British press
but you should not believe everything that is
written in any case it does not
always correspond to the truth and it is  falling from the
point raised by lisa rocard years has
never been in question we say on the side of
david frost nor on my side to abandon
the negotiation it is precisely the
opposite we want to intensify
we try to get closer by
always enough and it  we
continue to clarify to confront our
points of view and has worked or
has progress been made there is
progress of real convergences on
certain subjects such as the coordination of
social security land or the
programs of the union it is  important topics
I have the head that was
addressed to me that was addressed a few
days ago on cooperation in
universities
r erasmus research these are topics
where we intelligently we must
cooperate for the common good
in the times to come and  we
have offered the united kingdom as
we do for other third countries
norway switzerland to cooperate with us
in the case of bram horizon on research
issues  he in the
erasmus program for the justice rope i said
that we were ready to look for a
way with some flexibility
not to make a systematic reference to
the court since the british do
not want that at all that is what boris
johnson us  said obviously the price to
pay will be 108 to reduce the scope of
cooperation in certain areas I
take the example of certain points of
cooperation in judicial and
police matters and I will regret it but
this is one of the consequences of the
British request  concerning the
justice agreement we have in certain
specific areas the obligation to make
a reference to the court of justice when
it comes to the interpretation of
European law for the protection of the rights of
citizens and cannot do
otherwise
so if  we do not want the court of
justice probably we will be led on
certain subjects to reduce the scope of
our cooperation
lisbon the fine creation the protocol
on the irla  northern india and ireland is
very specific it is no longer a text
to be renegotiated it has been negotiated
it has been ratified approved by the house
of commons the british government
and the european parliament the leaders
of the european union
and  now it is a question of
implementing it methodically in a
concrete way by de-dramatizing the subjects in
an operational way for pres
hervé which is for me the most
important since the beginning in this
negotiation because it is not a question,
to be honest  the goods
of the technical trade it is about the
men and women who live in
ireland who haunt the memory of this
very hard conflict on an island or
fragile rabbits and therefore our responsibility
for the united kingdom and for us with
obviously
being  the european union the
dublin government
is to preserve the conditions of
this peace and this is the spirit in which
we negotiated with the two
successive governments in the united kingdom  i
and finally with noel johnson this
protocol on ireland and northern ireland
so i thanked
earlier michael gove and his team because i
think the british government
is sincerely committed to
implementing this agreement  for ireland
I know it's sensitive I know it
's difficult we have also
decided to cooperate with British interests
, particularly for checks
and control in belfast and we are going to
do it in an open and constructive way
simply we  we are vigilant
because time is passing quickly and there are
technical provisions of the
infrastructures and also legal conditions
which must be settled
week after week so that the treaty with
regard to the Irish protocol
effectively operational on
December 31 next match
I  I said earlier that if the
British positions on major issues
for the European Union do not move
a trade agreement becomes unlikely.
it is very difficult if the
British positions move as we have
moved on certain subjects so if I
can say
the October deadline and not
only realistically it is necessary
because we have to keep
these two months of November at the end and  of December
for the technical problems the
translations for example in all the
languages ​​of the European Union and not
only in English and for the
process of ratification by the
European Parliament and we must
respect the time necessary for the
European Parliament as we respect
the time  needed for the uk parliament
so hopefully
positions will move in the right
direction
and if so the october deadline
and it is
needed know the latest that when we
can get a deal done and the
correct
i  repeat because these two
sober col de siu battles excites
we must prepare for
very important changes which are the
me  bricks automatic canique
site in any event on january 1st
the simple fact that all
goods that will come from the
united kingdom anywhere in the single
european market must be checked it is a
considerable change in the same
way all goods that
will come from the european union within
the midday focus of your control is
normally any case we are preparing
for these controls and thousands of
additional customs posts have
been created veterinary
posts in the netherlands in belgium in france in
ireland and in  other countries so
it's a very important change
anyway and I would like to
say once again that the cumulative effect of these
checks which are mandatory which are
the reality of next January 1
the cumulative effect of these checks with
d  possible
additional constraints in terms of tariffs on
all these goods and quotas if
we do not have a trade agreement
this  are parties an
extremely serious cumulative effect for many
sectors that's me I don't work
for I noted light a skinny says I do
n't work for that I do
n't even work for a citrus quality
look we work for an agreement the
the sooner we can conclude the better
it will be gimont in the experience of
four years of negotiations with the
united kingdom it is that every day
counts when we have to finalize
our agreement in october
maybe at the end of october every hour
will count  also on condition that you have
done most of the work because
we are working on a text that will be
500,600 pages long it is a
legal text that we are talking about that protects
that gives guarantees on both sides
to institutions to citizens to
businesses
so  the blame games which evokes that
yanis we know him well
I was never impressed by this
blame game I always thought that those
who played this game of bling m per
their time and that we don't have a lot
of time to waste
I recommend that people know this kind
of argument we have brought our
points of view closer together on many subjects
we have the same objective I believe
of an ambitious agreement and  intelligent
in many areas even if I
regret that we do not cover all the
areas that are set out in the
political declaration, in particular
foreign policy and defense
perhaps that will come later I
simply hope that we respect the
British positions which must
respect the we respect each other their
sovereignty must respect ours
we have to find the points of
compromise agrees I simply repeat that with
regard to the conditions of entry into
our European market and a market of
450 million consumers  acting
on entry requirements for
UK products for UK services
including financial services
for state for
persons for  British companies
we set the
conditions of entry no one else
that's it it's our sovereignty we
respect British sovereignty in the same way
so I am
convinced that an agreement is possible and
we are working  for an agreement even
if today is difficult
first of all i would like to repeat extremely
clearly and in a very sincere way
that i have a lot of respect for
daily trust for the british team
as a whole an extremely
professional team  and competent
it does not surprise us because we
know the quality of
the British administration and I
respect the whole of the
British team which is in front of us and
which works under the authority and with the
confidence of boris johnson
when we negotiate as I have the honor
to do on behalf of the European Union
with the British Government is my
side under the control of the
European Council of the President of the
Commission  and from parliament
we listen to and respect what the
first Briton says and that's what
counts for us and for me so I
listen to and I respect young people take into
account what the first Briton says
I don't know d  'where does this
information come from I moreover gave him his
article yesterday morning in the telegraph the
timetable on which we are working
was fixed by mutual agreement more
than a month ago and therefore the working session
that we have which n  isnt a rand
next week i will be back in
london with 5 teams is
set over a month ago
so yes we will meet again
next week
it is a common need and then
alternatively brussels
and here the next one will make  place
from august 17 in the middle of next august
and in the meantime even if i
tell a gordon i will obviously 30
some days family vacation
like him no doubt gordon you
fancy taking a few days like
david frost
we c  we will continue to be working
always available to call to move forward
on the subject and to prepare the next
round of August 17
because once again time is running out
and every day every
week are weeks the ten days
useful to reach an agreement in  a
given point
[Music]